first we look at the past New Orleans is
a roller coaster of destruction and
rebirth
fire famine disease war
it always came down to two people
the divine Perry
[Music]
bloody [ __ ] Jimmy so I feel like I have
to be perfect
like I have to do everything right I go
the other way
we run away from everything I've had a
lot of things taken from me and
everything I have I've had to steal
there's something about fear that pushes
me how does my whole life whenever
anything goes wrong I hightail it out of
town
I think we need to talk
we touch take those bones assess our
limits
it's the same as it was for all the
others one will live and one will die
universe keeps pushing us together the
universe keeps pulling us apart
hey everybody is Charlie they just
dropped a trailer they're calling it the
official trailer for cloak-and-dagger so
I'll try to explain what's going on with
the series and what my plans are for it
in terms of making content so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
between Infinity Ward
Deadpool the TV shows they're just gonna
be a lot of Marvel stuff happening so
cloak and dagger Tyrone Johnson in Tandy
Bowen most of you are probably familiar
with a version of them from the comics
the reason why they're doing a why a
Riverdale looking style version of this
is because free form is the network
that's doing that that used to be ABC
family they mostly program for younger
high school college-age women so that's
really the audience that are going for
with this show there's actually a clip
of one of the freeform executives
talking about the show in how Jeff lobe
kind of laughed at them when they first
decided they wanted to do a Marvel
series he's like ABC Family
freeform there's no way you'd have
enough money to spend to make this look
awesome
but it actually does look pretty good
and if it's been a long time since
you've actually read a comic book or if
you've never read a cloak-and-dagger a
comic book story this actually seems
based on the last trailer that they
released to be based on the Ultimate
Marvel origin story of the characters
where there are two high school kids on
their way to the prom you find out that
they got into an accident then they got
involved in a Dark Matter experiment the
big villain of that comic book run is
Roxon so because there's a big rocks in
sign prominently displayed during the
trailer I'm guessing they're pulling
from that ultimate run the way like the
flash TV show pulls a lot from the Wally
West era of the comics even though it's
technically Barry Allen so if you are a
big comic book fan just remember that
the TV shows tend to change a lot of
things when dagger says we come together
things go boom that makes me wonder if
they've changed the mythology just a
little bit and it does have something to
do with either the dark force or the
dark force dimension because in the
comics when they come together nothing
particularly special happens unless
they're consciously using their powers
cloak wields the dark force it permeates
his body he can saturate himself with it
which is what makes him look really dark
he can use it to teleport he can use it
to phase through walls but in order to
do that like when you see him shivering
here he actually has to consume light
and if he's teleporting with someone
sometimes he winds up consuming light
from that person
destroying them in the process so
there's this vampiric aspect to it
because dagger gives off light it sort
of balances them out as sort of like
firestorm and killer frost going out
with each other like one person's power
sort of balances the other one out
the thing about daggers powers the light
that she gives off she can use to form
physical daggers like she throws during
the trailer she can also use that light
energy to purify people of sickness
addiction it also sort of helps alter
people's brain chemistry just a little
bit too so if you're really depressed
she can make you feel better about
yourself
hey was that supposed to hurt
I feel good very zen holy that was my
purifying blast left okay so now you can
fill me in on everything like why and
where cloak took my friend I don't know
it's as if cloak is under some kind of
spell or something few days ago those
things attacked us and he poured it away
but never next thing I know he's all
evil and capturing people so you get the
balance there you have this dark stormy
character with this really evil seeming
ability and then this really good light
bearing character on the other side of
things that come together but in the
trailer that explosion that they create
might have something to do with a dark
force reaction if you ever watch the
Asian CARTER TV series they also dealt
with the dark force a little bit it
becomes this sort of alternate energy
gone wrong situation like when they were
trying to manipulate the tesseract to
create the phase two weaponry during the
original Avengers movie or even the
agents of shield TV show which dealt
with the dark hold in the dark force
dimension which is mostly Ghost Rider
mythology so I'm actually wondering how
much of that they'll be able to do on
this TV show because Ghost Rider isn't a
really huge character on the TV shows at
the moment but when you get into dark
force Darkhold you start getting into
Mephisto territory I don't know how much
this show is gonna be able to do in
terms of big characters like that
because you have your human big bads
which sounds like it's gonna be rocks
and but you also need to have your
mythological big bads so I don't know
how Riverdale style this TV show is
going to be because they shoot Riverdale
like it's meant to be Twin Peaks so it
seems like there's a supernatural aspect
but in reality it's just a bunch of
teenagers running around a town they
just think that supernatural things are
going on because we're in the Marvel
Universe we know magic exists it's just
interesting to see what this is gonna
turn into Whittle probably end up
happening is as I'll do a video review
of the first episode but I don't know
that I'm gonna do videos for all the
episodes just because it feels like most
of my subscribers based on the stuff
they already like aren't gonna be super
down for this type of superhero show the
important thing to remember is that it's
on the
reform network and like I said they're
mostly programming for high school and
college age women so I think they're
hoping people watch this but like look
at the other TV shows that air on the
freeform Network it's gonna be a little
bit like that like Shadowhunters is
probably another good example so like if
you don't like those other shows you
might not be totally down for this but I
would recommend at least checking out
the first episode it doesn't premiere
till June 7th so it's still a little
ways off there'll be ten episodes total
but I'm assuming they're just gonna air
those continuously across the summer so
there won't be a lot of competition so
if you do get bored and look for stuff
during the summer this will be available
but I believe that the Deadpool
animated series will also be airing
during the summer which might be a
little more to your taste what in the
actual ass tail what are the visual
effects not done it's a metal arm it's
not like we're trying to remove a
mustache
[ __ ] it I'll do it myself
I'm cable and I'm from the future and I
like blowing [ __ ] up I'm getting a
little bit better about predicting what
TV shows are gonna look like based on
the network that they are on like when
we heard that HBO is making that
watchman TV series you just kind of know
what you're getting going into it's like
okay HBO got it it's gonna be pretty
hardcore
there is some new flash that I'm going
to try and post before the end of the
night but also new infinity war tomorrow
and then obviously Krypton Episode one
is dropping like I said a lot of
superhero TV shows dropping this year so
why you wait for everything click here
for that other cloak and dagger trailer
and click here for that Winter Soldier
infinity war preview thank you so much
for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight